democrats continue to foster the
creation of a woke elite class
aoc says pelosi and schumer should go
and fauci cancels christmas i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you're spending way too
much on your cell phone bill i know
because if you're spending with one of
the big companies
by necessity you are spending too much
on your cell phone bills why because
they are not clear about what you are
actually getting
for your money when you ask them they're
not going to be completely transparent
about what it is that you get they'll
tell you things like unlimited talk
unlimited text and unlimited data but do
you actually need unlimited data
the answer is you probably do not what
you actually need is unlimited
talk text and two gigs of data for just
20 bucks a month
your family could be saving over 800 a
year just by switching to pure talk
usa you don't have to sacrifice coverage
to do this by the way pure talk has the
same coverage same bars
as one of the big carriers but they will
charge you half so right now
grab your mobile phone dial pal 250 say
ben shapiro to get started on saving
money
on your cell phone bill again same
coverage as one of the big carriers and
you're spending like
a lot less money go check them out right
now and when you do when you dial pound
250 and say my name ben
shapiro you save 50 off your first month
again tile pound two five zero
say ben shapiro pure talk is simply
smarter wireless you're paying for what
you need instead of paying for a bunch
of stuff you don't need and you're
saving us
a bunch of money go check them out right
now dial pound two five zero say keyword
ben
shapiro get fifty percent off your first
month of pure talk
usa okay so there's an ongoing problem
in the country it's something i've been
talking about
for a while and that problem is of
course political division right
political polarization
and some of that is rooted in the fact
that there are real serious
disagreements about the future of the
country as i talk about my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
there are real divisions about what
people think about the history of the
united states what people think about
the philosophy of the united states
what people think about the culture of
the united states like real divisions on
where we want to go some people want to
end up in denmark
they mistakenly believe that if we apply
denmark's policies in the united states
we'll end up with denmark's results that
is not accurate
there are some people who wish to
preserve traditional american liberties
in the face of communalistic enterprises
these are very very different visions
but it used to be that thanks to the
federalist
structure thanks to the localism of the
united states government thanks to the
fact that the federal government was not
in charge of everything
and we had a system of checks and
balances that prevented mob rule
and pure majoritarian cram downs that
because of that
we were all able to live in a country
together you could live in california
and live like a californian and you
didn't have to live like a floridian or
a texan or an alabama
and the same thing the other way around
you could live in a town where people
agreed with you
and the next town over people would
disagree with you and you know what you
all shared the same country because you
shared the same
fundamental basic precepts a lot of that
seems to have been lost and that is
being exacerbated
right now by the creation of what
charles murray called and his great book
coming apart
he called the new elite class the new
upper class is what he termed them they
really are the new ruling class
and if you trace the origins of those
terms what you really get to
is something called the managerial elite
there was a an author named james
burnham
famous conservative author who sort of
started off as marxist
and he suggested back in the 1940s that
capitalism was creating
a new managerial elite meaning a group
of people who had graduated from college
who were in charge of managing the
economy who thought they were smarter
than everybody else they spoke their own
language they created their own cadre
and this has burst into full flower
because right now
what we have in the country are a new
managerial elite a new ruling class new
upper class
and they stand at the top of our
institutions they stand at the top of
the hollywood
infrastructure they stand at the top of
our mainstream media they stand at the
top
levels of administrative government they
stand at the top levels
of sport right every area of american
life
where institutions have power with
possibly the exception of some churches
all of those institutions are rife with
a managerial elite
a new elite class now when i say elite i
don't mean that these people are better
than you in any
real sense or better than me in any real
sense what i mean is that they are
deemed
elite because of credentialism because
they can point to their
degrees they can point to the fact they
went to really good schools but there's
something else that has happened
and it's not just that the meritocracy
has produced people who went to colleges
and now are in charge of things because
they went to colleges
in fact the truth is that so much of the
credentialism that happens in our
culture
is a lie and stupid right the fact is
that if you graduate top of your high
school class
and you don't go to college you're going
to perform at least as well as the
person who graduated middle of the high
school class and went to college and
graduated in the bottom 50
of their class in in college so college
is really not the dividing line
it's just that companies people around
the country typically use colleges
as a sort of way of rating and rating iq
we don't have these kind of broad iq
tests so instead what we have is people
looking at your degree and then thinking
you're smarter because you went to
college
than if you didn't go to college which
is a really blunt instrument and very
often
untrue it's one of the reasons why we
here at daily wire actually do not
require
a college degree in order to apply for
our jobs and we'd be hypocrites if we
did
considering that two out of the three
people who are at the top of the company
are not college graduates i'm the only
college graduate
at the top of our company and the other
two people who helped run the company
jeremy boring and caleb robinson
they're very smart guys neither one of
them graduated from college
i went to harvard law school right so
does that mean that i'm superior to them
in any real way no of course not
of course not okay so first of all the
credentialism is really bad but there's
something else that has happened here
and i could talk about the problems of
credentialism and and the breakdown
in america between sort of the
college-educated quote unquote elite and
everybody else
you could talk about that all day long
because it has created tremendous
pressures in the job market particularly
for non-college graduates it has led to
the rise
of people putting in job requirements
college admission even though they don't
really need it and if you're an
administrative assistant you really
shouldn't have to have
a college degree in order to get that
but now because 36 percent of americans
have gone to college as opposed to back
in 1960 when like five percent of
americans went to college
it has become the de rigor job
requirement even though
a degree in gender studies is not going
to make you a better administrative
assistant for example okay in any case
there's a bigger problem than that okay
a bigger problem than just the divide
between college educated and non-college
educated
that is the creation of a language that
is the creation
of an actual language that has happened
inside the new elite ruling class
so there's a process in evolutionary
biology it's called signaling
signaling happens in a wide variety of
contexts signaling
in evolutionary biology happens with
regard to reproduction you'll see that
certain birds for example have certain
plumage and this signifies that they are
ready to reproduce okay
in evolutionary biology terms signaling
is a way of
increasing your productive fitness
signaling is also a way of increasing
group productive fitness so what i mean
by that is that if you want your group
to be more efficient
then you can't afford to have kind of
long conversations about who is in the
group and who is out of the group
instead you look for simple signifiers
and the most
simple signifiers are going to be things
like the garb you wear right you can
tell by how somebody dresses
what they do i can tell if somebody
walks into a room wearing a white coat
there's a good shot that they're a
medical doctor
right if there's somebody who walks into
a room wearing a police uniform that is
a signifier right these are all
signifiers
okay but it is not merely you know dress
that is a signifier
it is also the activities that you take
so in religious communities they're
signifiers
so if you're an orthodox jew you are a
yamaka this is a signifier to the other
jews that you're an orthodox jew and it
comes along with a whole betty of
practices
the practices themselves could be seen
in evolutionary biology terms
as signifiers right it could be seen as
things that show solidarity with other
people who practice these things
as well as a gateway into the mind of
the person who's doing it right because
you've sacrificed things in order
to do this sort of signaling and the
signal is
is an establishment of social capital
with other people who share that signal
so this is why
thomas soul has talked about uh minority
middlemen in various cultures right it's
not just
orthodox jews and diamond industry in
new york right who don't actually have
to sign contracts because they have this
sort of shared
background they have this shared social
capital but for example
you'll see for example chinese
expatriates in in certain parts of
southeast asia
and they have created very solid social
capital connections
where they can trade more easily they
can they can do more things in terms of
commerce than they could do outside the
group
because they know and trust the people
that they are working with okay so the
united states used to have
a set of shared signals right all of us
had a set of shared signals those
signals
these are very important are things like
the flag right the american flag
i may disagree with you on tax rates but
we agree that the flag stands for
something good
right you and i we can disagree on a lot
of things but we agree that the military
is good
we agree that the founding fathers of
the united states did something
incredible we agree on the declaration
we agree on the constitution
all of these things are signaling fourth
of july parades our signaling
fireworks are signaling right all of
these things are signaling and they are
designed to create
in-group cohesion right so that we all
share something
and they are designed to also identify
people who are not going to share that
in-group cohesion as people you quote
unquote don't trust
okay what has happened in the united
states right now is the creation of a
new elite class who speaks a different
signaling language
they speak their own language and you
can see the signals everywhere once you
see they're speaking their own language
you understand so much of what's going
on
in american politics we'll get to what
exactly that language is
in just one second because it really is
fascinating and we're watching it happen
in real time and if you're wondering why
there's this political polarization
it's because there's been the creation
of a language that allows you access to
the highest halls of power it opens any
door it's like the shave in a haircut
shave in a haircut two bits knock right
down that gets you into the secret club
of the ruling classes and in that secret
of language right you can learn it
but it's a really ugly language and it's
a bad language and it has nothing to do
with reality we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you've had a lot to
deal with this year i think we've all
had a lot to deal with
this year don't overthink those holiday
gifts since we've all been living in
sweatpants anyway give your loved ones
some pro level tommy john lounge where
i'm talking
this is like the most comfortable stuff
you're going to own it is my go to
shabbat where when i am not in synagogue
this holiday season
tommy john is making sure you can give
the gift of comfort to everyone on your
list
and yourself with tommy john men's and
women's loungewear say goodbye to old
stained sweatpants tommy john loungewear
is luxuriously soft guaranteed to fit
perfectly
with the same level of comfort and
innovation that goes into everything
tommy sean makes
plus tommy john's loungewear pajamas
underwear come in limited edition sets
perfect for gifting but
they sell out quickly so tommy john go
check them out right now there's no risk
with tommy john's best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guarantee they have
great stuff for men they have great
stuff for women my wife
loves tommy john products order now go
to tommyjohn.com
ben for up to 30 bucks off site wide and
get last minute holiday deals for a
limited time only again get up to 30
bucks off for a limited time
at tommyjohn.com the best loungewear
underwear
their clothes just fantastic
tommyjohn.com they grace this
magnificent took us this very instant
tommyjohn.com
to get up to 30 off okay so
when we talk about signaling the
creation of the new upper class the new
elite right the new managerial class it
is not merely that they are united by
their college degree that is not enough
of a signal
is that they have created their own
language and that language requires you
to
speak a particular brand of jargon that
most people find
off-putting and also confusing because
it is both off-putting and confusing it
is not meant to convey information
it is meant to do the opposite it is not
meant to clarify it is meant to obscure
it is not meant to make yourself
understood it is meant to obfuscate
because everybody is speaking in code
and if you speak to code this means
you're a good person
and if you don't speak the code this
means that you are a bad person so
thomas edsel who writes
he's on the left but he writes a really
interesting column for the new york
times
it's kind of statistically based he has
a piece today in the new york times
titled america we have a problem the
rise of political sectarianism
is putting us all in danger and of
course he says that that is the
republicans right who are engaged in
political sectarianism
based on many republicans refusal to
accept the outcome of the election
okay but the reality is that what he's
about to describe is a
is a phenomenon that started on the left
and then there has been a
sort of a a reverse sectarianism that is
cropped up because people have been
reacting to the fact that they've been
excluded from the party
so there's a group of people in the
united states they decided that
everybody else was not in that group was
bad and then the people outside the
party they're like you know what you're
bad
that is that is the story of america
over the last 10 15 20 years
okay so here is uh here is what edsel
says he says on october 30th a group of
15 eminent scholars
several of whom i also got a chance to
talk to published an essay
political sectarianism in america
arguing that the antagonism between left
and right
has become so intense that words and
phrases like effective polarization and
tribalism
are no longer sufficient to capture the
level of partisan hostility
the severity of political conflict has
grown increasingly divorced from the
magnitude of policy disagreement the
authors right
so what they're saying is that people
hate each other more than you would
really think they should given how
our divides work in terms of
philosophical questions
they say that this would require the
development of a superordinate construct
political sectarianism the tendency to
adopt a moralized identification with
one political group and against another
political sectarianism they argue quote
consists of three
core ingredients othering the tendency
to view opposing partisans as
essentially different
or alien to oneself aversion
the tendency to dislike and distrust
opposing partisans and
moralization the tendency to view
opposing partisans as iniquitous
it is the confluence of these
ingredients that makes sectarianism so
corrosive
in the political sphere what is this
duel according to the authors this
incentivizes politicians to adopt
anti-democratic tactics when pursuing
electoral or political victories since
their supporters will justify such norm
violation because quote the consequences
of having the vile opposition win the
election are catastrophic
okay so i agree with a lot of this
analysis i also think that we know who
started this okay the fact is
that for decades people who are on the
political right have been castigated as
immoral
people who are on the political left
have been castigated by the by the right
generally as misguided
right people on the people on the left
see people on the right as evil and
terrible and this has been true
my entire life there is a view on the
political left
that people on the right are bad human
beings who ought not be
in public company is something i've
noted on a personal level many times
i've invited a thousand different people
on the left onto the show very few of
them actually have the balls to appear
on the show and i'm talking about for
like a cordial conversation on the
sunday special and if you've ever
watched the sunday special you
understand it's not me grilling people
it's an actual just conversation
there are too many incidents like this
to to recall people rejecting invites
just to have a normal conversation not
even a debate just a normal conversation
it i remember one time i was with one of
the top podcasters if not the top
podcaster on the left and i said we
should do a crossover election special
he said
your people would be fine with it my
people would kill me that is the general
phenomenon i'm talking about i'm talking
about what i've termed the happy
birthday problem which is
even folks on the left with whom i am
friendly will text me happy birthday but
they will never publicly say happy
birthday on twitter unless they
acknowledge that i was born of a woman
and
a messy human being right that sort of
thing is not actually uncommon when it
comes to the left right divide so let's
go back to those ingredients for a
second other ring
the tendency to view opposing partisans
as essentially different or alien
to oneself do you get that more from the
right or you get them more from the left
it certainly started on the left there
was this view that republicans were in
the words of barack obama bitter
clingers
who were clinging to god and guns and
xenophobia
in the words of hillary clinton if you
were deplorable you're a person
who believed in religion and that that
belief in religion had to be rethought
okay aversion the tendency to to dislike
and distrust opposing partisans okay i
mean just
in the last two days general malley
dylan who's going to be one of the top
staffers in the
biden team right she came out and she
said that republicans were
efforts and so aversion is definitely a
strong reaction it is the reaction
that people on the left have to people
on the right people on the right do not
have that same strong version of people
on the left it's just not something i've
seen
if they do it as a minority phenomenon
and it is a very recent phenomenon
more importantly for as long as i have
been alive people on the right have been
treated
as though they are as though they are
social lepers in the context of being in
liberal environments
and finally moralization the tendency to
view opposing partisans as iniquitous
right so basically we are talking here
about what what almost seems to be a
religious worldview which is why the
authors of this study are using the term
sectarianism normally when you use the
term sectarianism
you're not talking about politics you're
talking about religion you're talking
about shia versus sunni or catholic
versus protestant before the peace of
westphalia
and you're talking about sect sects that
fight each other because they have
mutually exclusive views of the world
okay so how do those sex connect with
one another how do you determine who is
in what sect
and here is where the signaling that i'm
talking about comes in
that signaling again has nothing to do
with an actual
cohesive political point of view it has
to do with signaling to other people
that you are part of the in-group
and you can see it and how folks on the
left now approach language i can see it
clearly over and over and over again
this is not meant the linguistic
tricks that the left likes to play are
not meant to make politics more clear
they are meant to be a screen right
there they are essentially
just a a sifter to make sure that people
who don't speak the language don't get
through
we'll get to what exactly that language
looks like in just one second because
the signifiers are everywhere around you
and if you've been wondering what the
hell people are talking about
they're just speaking in pig latin right
it's pig latin it's just a way for for
them and their friends to know
what exactly they are they are talking
about that they are they're part of the
same ingroup we'll get to that in just
one second first
let us talk about the fact that your
business you've had to get flexible
you've had to be fast acting
during this pandemic well this is why
you need zip recruiter
businesses have had to be flexible this
year from working remotely to pivoting
their business models for long-term
survival and growth
if you're in charge of hiring for your
business these pivots have made your job
even more challenging especially
if you have to hire for brand new roles
thankfully there's one place you can
always count on to make hiring faster
and easier ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job boards with one click then zip
recruiter's powerful technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job and actively
invites them
to apply it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate
within the very first day see for
yourself right now you can try zip
recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire that is
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-dailywire.com
ziprecruiter.com dailywire that is how
you're gonna get that special deal let's
zip recruiter take hiring off your plate
you can focus on growing your business
get the best possible employees and by
the way if you are a prospective
employee you can hook up with employers
really quickly and easily head on over
to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way
to hire okay so the the code that has
been created is not a code
that unifies members across classes
it is in fact a class-based code in
order to understand it you have to have
gone to a university
and you have to have studied inside the
sort of
intersectional philosophy of
universities you have to get woke
right you have to understand that all
the structures that surround you are
simply structures of oppression and
power
right this is a language it's not a
philosophy as much as it is
a language and it alienates everybody
right the the folks on the left who push
this sort of stuff
are the sort of folks who insist on
terms and you can you could see again
here's the code okay
if somebody uses the word latinx they
are part of this right if somebody uses
the word listings it's because they are
signaling to their other members of the
left that they are a member of their
sect
and that you are not a member of the
sect they speak the lingo
this is why by the way trump won a
larger share of hispanics
than in the past because many latinos
do not actually speak this language many
latinos look at this language and say
what the hell are you talking about
that's not how we talk about ourselves
but if you're on the left to understand
it is not about reaching out to latinos
by using the term what hinks is
the reason they are using what tanks is
because it's a part of gender theory
right the basic idea is that the term
latino is male
there are such things as female latinas
and so since you are saying latinos
and the plural encompasses latinas as
well instead they just say latinx's okay
you know how many people who are latino
care about this
particularly women who are latino zero
zero it's like they've taken polls of
this
latinos do not want to call themselves
listings because it's bullcrap it's
nonsense they understand how their own
language works
they understand how gender terminology
works
okay but it's not about reaching out to
latinos it's about reaching out to
fellow members of the intellectual elite
it is about reaching out to other
members of the ruling class
right here here's another way that you
can tell right here is more of the the
signaling and again it's about in-group
signalling it's about creation
of a hard upper caste cased who are who
are not going to accept
you into their realm unless you speak to
an and unless you
abide by their language okay so here's
another example
anybody who puts their gender pronouns
in their twitter profile
or in the bottom header of their email
is part of this and i'm not saying this
is a conspiracy it's not a conspiracy
we all do this sort of soft signaling
every day right we all use signals that
generate
commonalities between us and other
people we do it all the time but
this is its own language and it's
developing into its own it's got its own
lexicon
it's got its own jargon it is connected
to some deeper philosophical roots
springing all the way back to
deconstructionism
uh to bring back to jacques derrida and
and folks like michelle foucault
like there's their actual deep roots to
get into those deep philosophical roots
would take a little bit of time
the basic synopsis is this the
deconstructionist movement believed that
there is no such thing as objective
truth
that everything is shaped by the
language we speak and therefore
that all language is representative of
structures of power
okay the left has taken that up and they
have grafted onto it identity politics
so deconstructionists would have said
that race itself is a social construct
many of the gender and identity politics
folks will say simultaneously that race
and gender are social constructs but
also that they are deeply important
for understanding how the world works in
terms of its systems of power
these are mutually exclusive
propositions none of that matters
because most people who speak this
language don't even understand the
philosophical roots of their language
it's all about the signaling so here's
some of the signaling if you are using
g and j and they and them
to refer to an individual human being
this is because you're signaling in
group solidarity this is why
like everyone could just assume that if
you are a
female who identifies as a female then
we're going to use she and her
but you see people who are putting this
in their twitter profile not out of
solidarity with the
with the transgender community but
because they wish to show that they are
part of the woke
they are part of the enlightened so now
we have this but and the people who do
this are at the tops of our
institutional culture
this is why you have cartoon network
which it's a cartoon network yes they
have adult swim
but it is a network that is meant for
children now attempting to indoctrinate
children in this particular lexicon
because it's not enough
that they speak this language it's that
you have to speak the language too in a
sectarian war you have to make sure that
people know the rights and people know
the rituals and this is part of the
rights and rituals
is adopting this sort of bizarre
language and this bizarre philosophy of
gender that nobody actually
understands because it is utterly
internally incoherent
so cartoon network put out a tweet
yesterday here's to not only normalizing
gender pronouns but respecting them too
whether you use he she them or something
else we acknowledge and love you
right because this is all the things
right this is the the elements that were
just mentioned in edsel column
right but by that tweet signifies all of
them right it's othering if you don't
agree with us then you're a member of an
out group
it is treating people as though they are
bizarre
and exterior if they and it is
moralizing you are not loving and you
are not good unless you use the sort of
language that we want you to use even if
that language
is actually counter to reality counter
to biology and counter to the ability to
communicate clear ideas
so they put out this this tweet and it
has several graphics of cartoon
characters
one cartoon character says gender
pronouns describe a person's gender
identity
another one says examples of pronouns
are she her they them
and jesus a third
character says a lot of people are
learning about gender if you're
comfortable you can share your own
gender pronouns
and then it says underneath gender
pronouns we can't tell someone's gender
just by looking at them
and shouldn't assume we know there are
many gender identities beyond girl or
boy
some people don't identify as any gender
okay this is just indoctrination into
nonsense because there is no biological
basis to this
it's just semantic game playing but it's
not about actually making the world a
better place it's about in-group
signaling that you are a member of the
loving woke
hey that's what cartoon network is doing
right there and if you refuse to speak
the language
then you are cast out into the outer
darkness and this sort of language
characterizes everything that is
happening in our politics right now
gavin newsom yesterday he was tweeting
out about the trump administration
saying it would be cutting 200 million
dollars in federal healthcare funding to
california because the state requires
insurance providers to cover abortions
right which is a normal political issue
you'll see democrats attempt to hold
back funds based on pro-life positions
you'll see republicans attempt to hold
back funds based on
anti-life positions here's gavin
newsom's tweet nothing like the pro-life
party eliminating health care during a
global pandemic california will survive
without this
dollars for now but their frail pathetic
patriarchal system they are so desperate
to protect won't right that is that is
in group signaling when he uses the word
patriarchal you might say yourself wait
gavin newsom is a dude isn't he
yes he is you might say isn't he the
governor of california you know the head
of that
system yes he is you might say well
isn't that system
like wasn't that created by men the one
that he's taking advantage of yes it is
it's not about that it's about signaling
to everybody else he speaks the lingo
the lingo again that secret knock the
lingo is terms like patriarchal
terms like systemic injustice terms like
jesus
right all of this crap is designed for
one thing and one thing only and that is
to create
a secret handshake of the upper crust
that's what that is we'll get to more of
this in a second because you see
how this is is both driving a backlash
and also how this has infused every
aspect of the democratic agenda this
language is more important than the
actual policy we'll get to that in one
second first
what do millions of americans and three
former u.s presidents have in common
well they all agree that bowling brand
sheets are the softest most comfortable
pure organic cotton sheets
on earth we've all been spending a lot
of time at home you haven't really
thought about the sheets on your bed
you really should because it makes a big
difference you're spending hours and
hours every night upon
those sheets bulletin branch cotton it's
rain fed pesticide free carries the
highest organic certification that's why
it's so soft
because they work with family-owned
mills all over the world to expertly
weave every set of bowl and brand sheets
with the highest level of craftsmanship
it's quality you can feel
the moment you open the box and since
they sell direct to you
bowling branch sheets start at just 160
bucks they are thousand dollar quality
for a fraction of the price plus you can
sleep on them for a month
risk-free so you can try them out
bowling branch sheets by the way they're
so good that when i got them
we literally had to throw out all of our
other sheets like they just were not up
to snuff that's how good bowling
branches they ruined other sheets for us
right now
you'll get fifty dollars off any sheet
set at bulletinbranch.com with promo
code ben shapiro makes a great holiday
gift
it is spelled b-o-l-l and branch com
promo code ben shapiro for 50 bucks off
bowlingbranch.com promo code ben shapiro
restrictions may apply 200
order minimum see bulletin branch.com
for details
alrighty so the the sort of in-group
work signaling does drive a reverse
signaling on part of the right but that
signaling used to be stuff that people
sort of considered
rote and uncontroversial so for example
the left is very angry today because
david perdue and kelly lefler both the
senators from georgia who are in very
competitive runoff races right now
opposed renaming the atlanta braves and
people like why are they even commenting
on this the answer is because this is
also a form of in-group signaling
this is signaling to their own
constituents that they are not a member
of the woke elite class
they are not going to speak that
language so a counter language has
formed in rejection
of this language now i'm not saying
they're wrong because they're not i
totally agree with them i don't think
that the atlanta braves is an insulting
name i don't think the cleveland indians
was an insulting name
i mean even if you want to make the case
that the washington redskins was an
insulting name which again is
controversial and i don't
really agree with even if you want to
make that case there's a world of
separation between using the term
and using the term indians braves or
like kansas city chiefs right that
you can see the difference on its face
three of those terms cannot even be
construed
as as derogatory toward a particular
group of people
okay but the the idea here from lefleur
and purdue is this is again
a form of in-group social signaling it
is saying that the wokes
should not be able to take away sort of
common items that we used to hold in
common
so lefleur and purdue released a joint
statement on monday they said not only
are the braves of georgian institution
with a history spanning 54 years in
atlanta they're an american institution
the braves name honors our nation's
native american heritage which should
not be erased under no circumstances
should one of the most celebrated teams
in sports cave to the demands
of the canceled culture and the radical
left
only 20 percent of georgia voters
surveyed said they believe that the
baseball team needs to change its name
more than 70 of voters say the name
should be kept that is one of the
reasons why they are making that move
and that's one of the reasons they're
saying this sort of stuff because so
much of our culture war
is reliant on this linguistic semantic
war the
the language is reflective of the deeper
culture war that is taking place
and now you can see in the in the biden
team the adoption of this language
you can see it everywhere in the
adoption of of the the language of the
radical upper class elite okay so joe
biden he comes into
he comes into office january 20th the
electoral college has voted
and he's going to be speaking this
language nonstop now he's going to lie
he's going to say that he's a unifier
that if you speak this language it is
essentially a in a dis-unifying language
it is it is the language that suggests
the inferiority of your political
opponents
so biden has decided on a few of his
appointments that are worthy of note
okay so his first appointment that was
that was getting all sorts of play is of
course p
of course uh pete booty judge so p booty
judge was nominated as secretary of
transportation or he will be nominated
as secretary of transportation when they
have the ability to do so
and the media of course are slobbering
all over themselves that people judge
will be nominated as secretary of
transportation
so here is a jeff bennett on msnbc
reporting
this really is the culmination of pete
buddha judge's
meteoric rise in national politics over
the last two years it is nothing short
of remarkable
that a president-elect would elevate
someone to run an agency a 90 billion
dollar
agency with some fifty thousand
employees and the person he's elevating
has never worked in washington politics
and has never run
any part of a federal bureaucracy but
joe biden believes that pete buttage
is a special case okay so i love how
msnbc is reporting this
right it's with a smile on their face
right sure pete booty judge doesn't know
the first thing about transportation
policy sure he didn't even fill the
potholes in south bend
real story domino's pizza had to donate
money to fill potholes in south bend
while he was mayor
but he's a unique case he's uni so what
makes him a unique case
hmm hmm what could make people judge a
unique case what makes him so unique
well why don't you let the media tell
you by the way everything they're about
say here is false rick grinnell was the
first cabinet level official who is
openly gay under trump who's the acting
dni director of national intelligence
for a period
anyway here is the entire media
suggesting what is actually special
about people to judge
and that is of course his identity as a
gay man buddhist would become
the first openly gay cabinet secretary
confirmed
by the u.s senate in nominating peter
jet she is nominating
someone who would be the youngest
cabinet secretary ever
also the first openly gay cabinet
secretary
in american history judge would be the
first openly gay cabinet secretary in
u.s history
former mayor of south bend indiana would
beat one of the youngest cabinet members
since alexander hamilton and the first
openly gay cabinet secretary
pete better judge if confirmed would
also be the first
openly gay member of mr biden's cabinet
so many um historic firsts i guess as
well
okay so that's all that matters right it
doesn't matter whether he's qualified
for the position
and unless you feel this is a very
important thing that somebody who is
openly gay becomes the second
second person to serve in a cabinet
right
you heard that the first person actually
said one thing that you hear them
qualifying it
right some of them will say well he'll
be the first openly gay cabinet
secretary approved by the senate
because rick grinnell was not approved
by the senate he was he was an interim
replacement as acting director
of national intelligence which honestly
now you're having to really stretch
now you're like well look at that you
know this person was the
first person to the chinese were the
first people to land on the moon
that side of the moon in this century
really okay i mean true as far as it
goes you might be missing some things in
that in that particular story in any
case the real reason that people who
judges beloved of the left is because he
speaks the language to the left
so here was people who judged yesterday
talking about transportation and he's
about to drop
just a a hot bevy
of lingo woke lingo all over you right
that's what this is again this is all in
group signaling here is people to judge
doing some in-group signaling
about the power of transportation to
shape and then
insert woke buzzword here we go
at its best transportation makes the
american dream
possible getting people and goods to
where they need to be
directly and indirectly creating
good-paying jobs
at its worst misguided policies and
missed opportunities
can reinforce racial economic
and environmental injustice this
administration can deliver policies
and resources that will create jobs
rise to the climate challenge and
equitably serve
all americans okay so you can hear the
lingo right equitably right not not
not serve all americans you know with
regard to equal rights
but equitably right it can it can change
economic injustice what the hell is
economic injustice
and normally when you speak about
justice that's a term everybody
understands people get what they deserve
economic injustice suggests that in a
free market
he should be using the power of the
roads redistributing income or
environmental justice what does that
mean like justice for the earth
no it means that the entire system is of
course broken and you need the
government to come in
and fix the system right these are all
buzzwords right he's speaking at the
lingo
that is the important thing about p
booty judge which is one of the reasons
why he
he people who shares a position as a
member
of the new ruling class with the members
of the media who also speak this
language
they use exactly the same kind of
buzzwords and they're reporting like
exactly the same kind of buzzwords
in their reporting all the time okay so
they
and buddha judge have more in common
than you and the media the media have
nothing in common with you
you don't speak the language they're
speaking but they speak the language he
is speaking
they may as well be speaking norwegian
with each other while you and the media
just are speaking completely different
languages this is why there's this wide
disconnect that is opening and this is
why the media will just look the other
way at the fact that people who judge
has no qualifications whatsoever
to be secretary of transportation i
remember when dr ben carson was
nominated
the head of housing and urban
development i picked it even i thought
was somewhat bizarre since he had no
actual expertise
in housing or urban development the
media went nuts on that i thought okay
well you know
that's kind of true i mean dr carson was
a neuroscientist like he was a
neurosurgeon
but i hold the same standard p booty
judge has no
no expertise on this sort of stuff
doesn't matter the media are just in
love with him
by the way what is pete booty judge's
actual claim to to
be qualified for this position here was
his actual claim to be qualified for
this position
i've also had a personal love of
transportation ever since childhood
more than once as a college student i
would convince a friend to
travel nearly a thousand miles back to
indiana with me on amtrak
though i know that in this
administration i will at best aspire to
be the second biggest
train enthusiast around i spent a spring
break in graduate school
aboard a cargo ship studying there
travel in my mind
is synonymous with growth with adventure
even love so much so that i proposed to
my husband chaston
in an airport terminal so
he should be secretary of transportation
because he loves choo choo trains
and has loved choo choo train since he
was a child by
which by which metric my four-year-old
son
should be secretary of transportation
also
if i got to say if you think that
airport terminals are like a really
romantic place i suggest you visit
newark
sir airport
yes nothing says romance quite like
being in a place
filled with people who are farting and
taking off their shoes
that is that that is the essence of
romance to me as well it is
it is the peculiar grime of lax that
really gets my heart a flutter
also by the way even if you love airport
terminals i mean you really have to love
airport terminals
uh then i i'm wondering how that makes
you qualified to be secretary of
transportation like i propose to my wife
for the record in her college
residential
dorm and um that would not qualify me to
either be secretary of education or
secretary of housing and urban
development
so that that's a weird take but the
media are just gonna look right past
that none of that matters because he
speaks the language
he speaks the language and we're going
to speak in a second about people
who by nominated who didn't quite speak
the language and now he's going to have
to replace those people because they
didn't speak
the language we'll get to this in just
one second first
let us talk about the fact that you are
making a large mistake if you're not
protecting yourself against malware
and ransomware if you ever had
ransomware hit your computer it is a bad
bad thing or malware my goodness
that hits your computer and you're
basically screwed for like a month they
take your computer away
and they have to clean it they set it
back to factory settings it that's like
best case scenario
so what should you be doing well you
should head out and get pcmatic right
now it's a next generation antivirus
designed to stop modern threats like
ransomware
independent testing from av test just
named pcmatic as a top performer in the
cyber security industry giving it the
best performance award
for 2019 only pcmatic has american
research development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic will block annoying and
malicious ads for hassle-free web
browsing
makes your computer faster and more
reliable even after years of use pcmatic
protects windows computers including xp
vista windows 7 8 and 10
windows servers mac macbooks android
phones and tablets
it's just 50 bucks for five devices for
one year full 30 day money back
guarantee if you act right now
pcmatic has offered my listeners a free
month of security protection with the
purchase of that annual license to
access the offer go to pcmatic.com
protect your computer go do it right now
get world-class security that keeps your
computer running great go to pcmatic.com
ben can we get to more of this in just
one second the the
determination by biden and by the
democrats
to stack the top levels of power with
people who speak the lingo we'll get to
that in one second first
on monday december 21st the historical
docu series apollo 11 what we saw will
soon be available exclusively at
dailywire.com
originally released as an audio podcast
for apple and spotify what we saw will
be available to watch
as well as listen on daily wire apple tv
or roku app or
at dailywire.com that docu series takes
a detailed look at the apollo 11 mission
to land a man on the moon
it was the culmination of a heated
decades-long space race between cold war
rivals the us and the soviet union
the podcast explores one of america's
greatest accomplishments through the
eyes of the millions of americans who
lived through it
it's a dramatically inspiring story
apollo 11 what we saw go check it out
right now right now you get it for 20
off with code watch when you become an
insider or above member at dailywire.com
subscribe by the way when you become an
insider member or above at daily wear
get all sorts of goodies i mean we're
talking about like all access live we're
talking about your ability to have your
question read in the mail bag like all
sorts of good stuff happening go to
dailywire.com
subscribe get 20 off your membership
with codewatch and access to all of our
new and existing content
also make sure to tune in to daily wires
backstage this monday
the 21st 8pm eastern 5 pm pacific for a
special december christmas episode
uh backstage if you've never seen it
because it's been a while is where all
of the hosts get together and we all
hang out with one another
and they drink manly drinks and i drink
margaritas and and
cold good tasting slushy girly drinks
and it's fantastic
yeah you're going to want to you'll
enjoy it more than i will probably
because i have to be on set with these
guys but
it is really a lot of fun you'll enjoy
it go check it out right now become a
subscriber at dailywire.com
subscribe code watch for 20 off you're
listening it's the largest fastest
growing podcast and radio show in the
nation
so if you don't speak the upper cross
lingo doesn't matter if you're even a
political leftist
it means that you are out on your butt
here's a great example so according to
the new york times
claims of a bleak environmental justice
record appear to fell a biden favorite
now
you're a normal human and you say what
the hell is environmental justice are we
talking about like the sun has filed a
lawsuit
or the clean air or the water no that's
not what it means you big silly
what it actually means is that america's
racist systemically evil and that even
if you back
anti-climate change policies like cap
and trade policies or carbon
regulations that's not good enough
because you have to redistribute income
you have to redistribute everything in
order to wreck the system from the
inside and if you don't speak the
language of environmental justice even
if you are a far leftist when it comes
to climate change that's not good enough
you don't speak the lingo
so just like a lot of other religions
the more devoted you are to the religion
the more ritual you have to perform this
is also true when it comes to
woke signaling according to coral
davenport when joe biden won the
presidential election his top candidate
to lead
the nation's most powerful environmental
agency appeared clear mary nichols
california's clean
air regulator arguably the country's
most experienced climate change official
she was seen as a lock to run the epa
now biden's team is scrambling to find
somebody else according to several
people who have spoken with the
presidential transition team
the chief reason this month a group of
more than 70 environmental justice
groups
wrote to the biden transition charging
them this nichols has a bleak track
record in addressing environmental
racism
uh environmental race again this is all
jargon environmental racism
is an interior it's an internally
foolish concept
the environment applies to everyone
equally but and we all share it
this is one of the problems the tragedy
of the commons right but what they mean
by environmental racism
is that the impacts of particular
environmental policy fall unequally
on people and therefore it is the job of
the government to fix all of that and
this lady has not done enough to fix
all of that right in other words she has
not connected her sort of green new deal
ideas with a redistributionist far-left
program the way that
the aoc wing of the party would like the
environmental justice groups cited
nichols's rise role in pushing
california's cap and trade program which
is designed to broadly reduce pollution
and planet-warming greenhouse gases but
disproportionately does so at the
expense of the group said of communities
of color by exposing them to more
pollutants
like smog and soot the groups charge
that miss nichols had repeatedly
disregarded or dismissed the concerns of
those communities about the effects of
the climate policies
she enacted the letter appears to have
resonated one of biden's key campaign
pledges was a promise to address
environmental justice again
these are all buzzwords environmental
justice economic justice
systemic racism right all of this stuff
is meant just to signal
your allegiance to a particular
viewpoint and to a belief that you are
superior to everybody else
within the the political realm and this
is why
you're starting to see somebody like a
brenda mallory is going to be picked to
run the white house environment office
why here here's the new york times the
office the council on environmental
quality
is expected to have an expanded focus on
environmental justice
under miss mallory there it is there's
that signaling the new york times
understands it
biden understands it his people
understand it you don't know what the
hell they're talking about but they know
what they're talking about and that's
the important part
and if you don't understand what they're
talking about it's because you're a
member of the unwashed so keep your
mouth shut or just say environmental
justice over and over
until tinker bell redistributes income
all over the united states thus creating
environmental justice ms mallory
according to the new york times
who serves as director of the regulatory
policy at the southern environmental law
center a watchdog group has worked on
both pollution and land conservation
issues throughout her career
including helping to create new national
monuments under the obama administration
and fighting the dismantlement of those
monuments under the trump administration
biden has pledged to make addressing
racial disparities and environmental
policies a core part of his climate
agenda his climate
again when it comes to the the woke
language all this stuff
is lumped together right environmental
injustice economic justice racial
injustice all of this is just bald
together
so that the same policy solves all of it
redistributionism and if you don't
repeat their nostroms
it can't be part of the cool kids crowd
so who is part of the cool kids crowd
well there are now a couple of people
who biden is considering for secretary
of education
one is leslie fenwick dean emeritus of
the howard university school of
education
and professor of educational policy and
leadership
okay so we know something about uh
fenwick and the thing we know about
fenwick is that fenwick is a person who
speaks the lingo
we also know that fenwick is diverse
right as a candidate biden promised to
choose a public school educator as
secretary
raising expectations the nominee would
come from k-12 he's also expected to
name a person of color to the post
and most of the people considered have
been black and latino
or latino fenwick is black okay so here
is
fenwick speaking very recently there's a
video published in september
talking about ideas to broaden
educational opportunities for black
students
like for-profit charter schools and
taxpayer-funded private school vouchers
right things that allow school choice
particularly directed at inner cities
because kids in inner cities are stuck
at their crappy public schools
and what does she say about she says
they're bad they're not just bad by the
way they're evil
right they are schemes like she's
engaged in exactly this sort of
sectarianism political sectarianism that
thomas edsel was decrying in the new
york times
and she is being considered for the head
of the department of education here she
is declaring school choice
to be a scheme rooted in desire to
segregate
which is a really weird take considering
that school choice would specifically be
designed
at unsegregating formal informal
segregation right it would allow people
from the inner city to actually
take their kids and put them in a school
outside of their their school district
here she was
using the lingo and all that matters is
the lingo
the courts have challenged
vouchers charters
the placement of teachers in training
as teachers of record so this
disproportionate
placement of non-certified teachers
primarily in school serving black brown
and poor children
and these schemes are often viewed as
new and innovative but when you look at
the history
of these schemes and i use the word
schemes purposely
you find that they are rooted in
resistance to the brown legal decision
uh it's all it's all about again it's
all about trying to connect everything
to this broader narrative
and you have to understand the narrative
by speaking their magical language the
good news is that all of hollywood
speaks the language so you have the
entire educational infrastructure that
speaks the language in fact much of this
language was created inside
our ivory tower members of the
democratic party speak this language and
hollywood of course
speaks this language which is why you
are seeing folks like bob
iger being considered for ambassador to
china which makes perfect sense disney
was really
recently ripped like up and down this
year because they filmed mulan in
xinjiang province
which is the area where the uyghurs are
being kept in concentration camps
and espn has been ripped up and down for
being pro-china pro-chinese so naturally
biden's like you know who
we should make ambassador to china the
head of disney espn makes perfect sense
makes perfect sense other people who are
being considered and also speak the
lingo people like jeffrey katzenberg
the head of dreamworks other people
susan rice
she stepped down she was on the board of
netflix and she uh stepped down to join
the white house domestic policy council
nicole avant former ambassador to the
bahamas during the obama administration
wife
of netflix co-ceo and chief content
officer ted sarandos is seeking a return
to diplomatic life yeah i mean if you
made me ambassador to bahamas i'd also
love to be
in diplomatic life that sounds pretty
spectacular
so good times all the way around it's
all about the creation of this
specific elite cadre that is what the
entire thing is about
and you're not part of that cadre you
are not because you don't speak the
language or you refuse
to speak the language now the bad news
is that inside the the coalition of the
new ruling class
the language is constantly shifting you
always have to go one level up
right you thought that you were woke
enough you thought that you were social
justice oriented enough but now there's
another level
right all you have to do is pay the
grifters a little bit more money so you
can learn the new language and then you
you two will rise in a steam and you can
maintain your membership it's like an
ongoing club membership you have to just
continue to use more and more
bizarre language and this is the this is
what the squad is doing
because the squad are the most devout of
the devout they're like the most devout
members of the sect
and they get to dictate the terms for
the most about you want to be the
interior core
what you really need to do is acquiesce
to their use of language
okay and by the way once you're in the
club you cannot be cast out of the club
this is the good news once you're in the
club so long as you don't piss off the
other members of the club
no attack will have any impact on you so
you can be eric swalwell
in all likelihood having sex with a
chinese spy and you will still maintain
your position on the intelligence
committee because you are a member of
the club you speak the language here's
hakeem jeffries
one of the higher ups in the democratic
congress saying that eric swalwall would
he why would we take him off the intel
committee i mean he was only probably
effing a chinese spy why would we why
do you think that jeopardizes national
security i mean
hell it's not like it's not like he had
a phone call as the incoming national
security adviser with the russians or
something
he was only having sex with a chinese
spy in all likelihood here's hakeem
jefferies
well i believe speaker pelosi has
addressed this issue she's got full
confidence in representative swatwell i
have full confidence
in representative swabal i served with
him on the judiciary committee as well
he's been a tremendous member
okay meanwhile you've got john ossoff
who's running for georgia senate right
now
and he too is engaged in this sort of uh
buzzwordification
here he was saying that uh all the gop
attacks in
georgia have been racist and
anti-semitic which is a weird take
considering that rafael warnock is an
open anti-semite who has defended
jeremiah wright and louis farrakhan and
campaigned with linda sarsour over the
weekend
i think that the gop attacks at this
point are garden variety
fear-mongering race-baiting look they've
been lengthening my nose in their ads to
remind everybody that i'm a jew they've
been running racist attacks against
reverend warnock
it sounds like you're saying the
republican attacks are functionally
racist
and potentially anti-semitic well when
they're lengthening my nose and their
ads and when they're
calling reverend warnock dangerous i
mean look this is the playbook that
they've run here since the 1970s the gop
southern strategy in the south is to
divide people along
i had no idea assaf was jewish like
really like no idea assaf was jewish
i'm not sure why i would care
exactly but as far as warnock being
dangerous he is dangerous he's a marxist
that's kind of dangerous to have in the
united states senate now the only good
news for people who don't speak to lingo
is that again the lingo gets more and
more rigorous which is why you have
alexander ocasio-cortez honorable
representative d twitch
saying that it may be time to move on to
the next generation of people who speak
the new lingo because of course the
dictionary
of wokism gets remade every few years
here is alexander ocasio-cortez saying
it's time to move
beyond the current democratic leadership
into a new era of more woke language
i do think that we need new leadership
in the democratic party
i think one of the things that i have
struggled with i think that a lot of
people struggle with
is the internal dynamics
of the house has made it such that
there's
very little option for succession
if you will you know and i think that
one could just
i think it's easy for someone to say oh
well you know why don't you run
but the house is extraordinarily complex
and
i'm not ready it can't be me i know that
i couldn't do that job
oh yeah unt until the next five minutes
when she declares that the the old folks
yeah i mean she already did this right
about a year ago she suggested that she
was going to turn the language of woke
on the democratic leadership so that's
the only good news is that the woke tend
to eat their own if they don't move fast
enough with them
okay so how do you reject all this the
way that you reject all of this is by
rejecting the language of vocalism
the language of vocalism has to be
rejected at every term okay meanwhile
let us talk about the latest
developments with regard to kovid
so right now a coveted relief bill is
on the table according to cnn
congressional leaders after months of a
bitter stalemate and as millions of
americans have been eager for relief are
finally indicating they're nearing a
deal on a new rescue package that could
pass both chambers
within days it was pretty obvious the
democrats were holding this thing up so
they could blame republicans nancy
pelosi said so openly she said we
weren't going to do this
in the lead up to the election because
now we've had an election and now things
are magically different
and mitch mcconnell acknowledged the
other day that pelosi
has basically succeeded in this because
the media are her lap dogs and they'll
do whatever
they whatever she wants them to do and
the media will simply suggest that
republicans held up a relief bill when
they did not they proposed a relief bill
what four months ago the democrats have
been holding up
over and over and over they wouldn't
even allow a vote on it meanwhile
the the republicans have passed that
relief bill a bunch of times in the
senate
okay but the media because they lap up
whatever the
democrats tell them then vomit out on
the vomited out on the rug like a good
dog
or like a bad dog is the case maybe they
have been able to promulgate the idea
that republicans are the obstructionists
here so this has pushed mcconnell
into a bit of an uncomfortable position
where something has to get passed or
presumably the georgia senate race
starts to get dicier even than it
already is for republicans
according to cnn the price tag for a
stimulus deal could be close to 900
billion dollars
the deal is expected to include a new
round of stimulus checks at 600 bucks
per individual
no money for state local aid democrats
have pushed that no lawsuit protections
which republicans wanted so it sounds
like mcconnell actually is going to get
his way he proposed this deal last week
pelosi rejected the deal that sounds
like the deal that is going to go
forward
the measure is also expected to include
an additional 300 bucks a week in
jobless benefits
as well as up to 330 billion dollars for
small business loans and money for
vaccine
distribution which means that overall
you're talking about 600
per individual plus 300 bucks a week in
jobless benefits so minimum of 1800
per individual to take you for
presumably the next couple of months
you know that that leaves aside the fact
that again if it's 600 per individual
then there's usually more
more than one individual in the
household senate majority whip john
thune told cnn
that uh there may be a simple way that
the democrats are disguising money for
state and local governments because
democrats are trying to push to include
90 billion dollars in native states
administered by the fema agency by the
federal emergency management agency
it's still uncertain when congress is
going to vote and whether they're going
to tie that 900 billion
relief plan to a massive 1.4 trillion
dollar spending bill congress is trying
to pass by the time the government
runs out of money on friday night
because again there's budget
issue that's also happening congress may
have to pass another stopgap measure to
keep agencies afloat
mr mcconnell suggested that votes on
final passage could slip into the
weekend
if that happens it's possible there
could be a temporary government shutdown
until final passage that's gonna last
for like five seconds
mcconnell said in a floor speech on
wednesday hill leaders are making major
headway
again this thing should have passed two
months ago the fact that the democrats
are calling for unending aid
in the middle of a pandemic in which
they are calling for basically total
shutdown until
the end of time is somewhat telling
there are a lot of people who are
enjoying lockdown too much
and the people who are enjoying lockdown
too much tend to be the people who don't
have to work for a living
those people seem to be enjoying
lockdown an awful awful lot or whoever
is able to scam the government out of
money
now this doesn't mean that we shouldn't
be careful in how we approach the
pandemic
but the reality is that every business
that operates is an essential business
for the people who operate it and the
people who work for it
and we have to find ways that those
businesses can operate safely and
securely
speaking of which the notion that
lockdowns are a cure-all i'm wondering
why that is that california then is
experiencing this massive massive spike
according to the washington post
california is the new epicenter of
america's coronavirus crisis with
unprecedented surges of seriously
infected patients
threatening to overwhelm hospitals and
overflow morgues the state is reporting
unnerving numbers california has had
nationwide records for new cases again
and again in the past week most recently
on wednesday when it posted more than 41
000 infections you know why
because people are not going to listen
to blanket lockdowns end of story
people are simply the the tighter you
grasp this thing
the more people are just going to avoid
the grip if you told people to be
responsible with their and they're
responsible for their own health
and now you need to actually act
reasonably to protect other people
i think most people do that and the
statistics show that people do mask up
when they go into public areas and
people take seriously the pandemic when
the pandemic starts to hit their area
when you tell people they have to lock
down until the end of time and there is
no future
of openness in sight and then when you
add on top of that ridiculous statement
like was made by dr gupta on msnbc
yesterday in which he suggested
that people are still going to be
masking and social distancing
through like 2022 or that after you have
the virus
you still shouldn't travel after you
have the virus and you're okay you
shouldn't travel
or after you have the vaccine you
shouldn't travel fauci said yesterday
that we are not going to be able to stop
them asking in social distancing
until like the end of 2021. you think
people are going to pay attention to
that
people are tired of this we've been
doing this since march and guess what
what we are seeing
is that in places that lock down
incredibly tight like california we are
still seeing
this rapid increase nonetheless
the uh the the push for more lockdowns
continues
joe biden came out yesterday he was
asked about school reopenings
here's how radical the democratic party
is on this lockdown stuff here's what
joe biden said quote
this was his moderate position he was on
a he was on a call with 31 governors
on zoom i know it's going to be
controversial for some of you but i'm
going to ask that we're able to open
schools at the end of 100 days
at the end of 100 days the hell are you
talking about
the end of 100 days after inauguration
day
that would put you like the end of april
okay that means that the school year's
over you're already at the beginning of
may
what are you even saying right now the
schools should be open
today for elementary school students
today
my kids have been in school since
september there hasn't been an outbreak
because you can act responsibly and you
can make sure that precautions are taken
the precautions in my kids school
involve that we have to actually sign a
basically an affidavit every night
saying that our kids aren't sick and
they haven't been in contact with
anybody with kovid
and the kids are wearing masks and there
are plexiglas shields
okay and their kids who by statistics
are really not getting sick from this
thing
and are also really not transmitting
this thing in high numbers
and joe biden is saying maybe after what
what bravery from joe biden moderate joe
biden maybe we'll open the schools after
100 days maybe
by may well yeah no bleep sherlock
by the end by that period everybody's
going to be vaccinated
that's something else fauci said earlier
this week i get the feeling our public
health officials are kind of full of
crap that's
that's the impression that i'm just
getting and again the catastrophic
coverage by the media
is driving people to ignore all the
rules here's the way it works when you
set up rules that people find are
unreasonable they just say screw all of
your rules
so here's a piece from natalie compton
in the washington post today
as americans grapple with the cdc strong
warning to stay at home this winter to
stop the spread of covet some are
wondering if they're exempt from the
recommendation if they've already
recovered from the illness
people who had coronavirus can develop
antibodies that circulate in the blood
and can neutralize the pathogen
but questions around immunity still
linger the cdc says cases of reinfection
have been reported but are rare
it hasn't stopped people from traveling
though i mean though of course it hasn't
stopped people from traveling
the infection on the information on
reinfection is extraordinarily scanty
they've been as far as i'm aware like
double digit recorded cases all over the
world
of reinfection happening in some of
those cases there are people who are
wondering if they had a false positive
the first time
and if you if you believe that having
this thing
and getting over it does not provide
immunity by the current data you're
operating against the science and
you're being told by the media that if
you have already had this thing you
still should not travel
i mean we were being told by the media
that even after you've had the vaccine
you still may transmit it to people
then what the hell are we talking about
here nobody is going to abide by your
dumb rules
if you make your rules dumb so make your
rules not dumb say not dumb things
go with the science instead of against
the science and by the way trying to
scare people into doing things is not
going to work
because eventually people are going to
get bored with the scare tactics because
either it materializes or it doesn't
last month the icelandic government
announced that visitors who have
recovered from covet
can skip the country's new border
measures when they arrive well obviously
the icelanders are trumpians that's
what's happened there
after recovering from coveted march
travel blogger and author matt kapnis 39
resumed traveling in the us and mexico
albeit with caution but should you
travel if you've already had coveted the
short answer is
no is no says the washington post
eric feigl ding epidemiologist senior
fellow at the federation of american
scientists agrees early on in the
pandemic many scientists
dismissed the threat of reinfection he
says we now know there are many cases of
reinfection including among patients in
their 20s 30s and 40s
it's not a once in a blue moon kind of
thing he says it's kind of like car
crashes are still
rare but when they do happen it's really
bad
okay so but and then he says that's why
you should wear your seatbelt yes but
now you're telling people that they
should just never drive or you're not
telling people to wear a seatbelt you're
telling people you're not saying you can
travel but wear a mask
you're saying don't drive at all it's
just it's wild stuff
meanwhile anthony fauci uh has become
the grinch he has cancelled christmas he
says you should not
get together with your family and i
understand
what he's doing i understand that he is
attempting to stop people who have
covered from traveling to areas that are
unhit
by covet but people are gonna do what
they're gonna do and he should be
encouraging people to be reasonable
that's what he should be focusing on
right now and i'm not aware that travel
is the chief vector of transmission for
the virus
in fact by statistics we're pretty sure
that it's not it's internal households
that are the chief vector
of transmission it is not restaurants
new york did contact racing it's not
restaurants
it is not schools it is not indoor or
outdoor dining
it is people in homes with other people
who live in their family
in any case fauci said the christmas
holiday is a special holiday for us
because christmas eve is my birthday
christmas day is christmas day they're
not going to come home that's painful we
don't like that that's just one of the
things you're going to have to accept as
we go through this unprecedented
challenging time yeah good luck with
that we'll see we'll see how that works
out
i have i have some doubts and meanwhile
speaking of media bias i just have to
bring you this
everything trump does is bad according
to media like every single thing
including things that are perfectly
obvious
so according to the washington post in
its waning days the trump administration
is proposing that employee performance
be a top factor during federal layoffs
now i know what you're thinking that
sounds pretty obvious right like if
you're gonna lay people off you should
do it by
lack of performance wouldn't that be
like the place to start well apparently
according to the washington post that's
super bad
in the latest of a string of moves to
put its stamp on federal workplace
policies the trump administration is set
to propose rules
to make employees performance ratings a
top consideration in deciding who stays
or goes during layoffs
i mean that's evil right we're actually
gonna decide how people perform before
we fire them
as opposed to just saying the old guy
gets to stay and the young guy gets
fired
a proposal to be published thursday by
the office of personnel management would
elevate job ratings across the consider
among the considerations during the
process called reduction in force
the proposed rules come within a 30-day
public comment period it's uncertain
whether the rules could be in place
before the inauguration january 20th
the move reflects a provision in a 2018
executive order stating agencies should
prioritize performance
over length of service in determining
who gets to keep their job
following those orders the already
tested relations between the
administration and employee unions
and their democratic allies deteriorated
further
the newly proposed regulations would
affect procedures agency use agencies
use when cutting their workforces for
reasons such as reorganizations or
budget restrictions basically creating
a pecking order among employees under
current procedures employees first are
divided according to whether they are in
permanent jobs or those with time limits
basically seniority
matters the only exception is the
defense department where performance
ratings
have been the top consideration because
it turns out that we have to have a
functioning military
jacques simone the public policy
director of the american federation of
government employees criticized the
proposal
there's nothing objective about in
performance ratings she said performance
ratings are highly subjective
under trump they were highly politicized
and now this and now this
so good times apparently the democrats
when they gain power plan to undo all
that and make it so that
worse employees get to stay on
government payrolls because of course
unions
good stuff all the way around okay we'll
be back here a little bit later today
with two additional
hours of content while you wait head on
over to the michael knowles show right
now
he will be discussing british scientists
demanding that we postpone christmas
otherwise we'll see you here later today
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clinton
you